science news ein neues kuschelhormon
wurde entwickelt wlan kann man sich
jetzt auch drucken andere drucken dafür
mit leben der tinten schwule männer
haben öfter ältere brüder und betrunken
beherrschen wir fremdsprachen besser und
damit herzlich willkommen bei science
news freunde der sonne setzt euch wir
haben keine zeit zu verlieren in der
welt der wissenschaft passieren so viele
dinge ich kann nicht über alles ein
video machen deswegen habe ich heute
direkt fünf brandaktuelle meldungen aus
der aktuellen forschung für euch let's
go nummer eins kuschelhormon 2.0 das
molekül oxytocin wird als kuschel oder
liebeshormon stark gehabt seine funktion
im körper ist wie bei so vielen hormon
komplex und vielfältig vor allem berühmt
ist es aber für seine rolle bei
zwischenmenschlichen beziehungen zum
beispiel zwischen mutter und kind oder
bei romantischen liebesbeziehungen
eingesetzt als medikament hilft oxytocin
nicht nur bei geburten sondern
potenziell auch bei krankheiten wie
krebs autismus angststörungen und viele
mehr allerdings kann das kuschelhormon
als medikament auch schädliche
nebenwirkungen für herz-kreislauf- oder
die gebärmutter haben denn oxytocin
spricht nicht nur den oxytocin rezeptor
an sondern auch den sogenannten base
pressen rezepte und damit es eine
selektive wirkung erschwert jetzt haben
forscher oxytocin nachgekocht allerdings
das molekül minimal verändert so dass es
jetzt viel selektiver nur auf den
oxytocin rezeptors bleiben gespannt wie
sich das kuschelhormon 2.0 therapeutisch
einsetzen lässt nummer zwei gedrucktes
wifi was freunde der sonne sind keine
selbst gemacht und kinderspielzeuge
sondern 3d gedruckte haushaltshelfer die
ohne strom über wlan mit dem handy oder
dem laptop kommunizieren können diese
smarten gegenstände beruhen auf einem
eigentlich einfachen prinzip ein
schalter eine feder ein zahnrad und eine
einfache antenne die antenne kann ohne
strom signale empfangen und aussenden
zum beispiel an ein handy
indem sie das wlan signal entweder
reflektiert oder absorbiert dieses
physikalische phänomen nennt man ambient
becks
das heißt immer wenn sich das rädchen
dreht berührt der schalter die antenne
und immer wenn der schalter die antenne
berührt verändert dass die reflektion
des wlan signals wenn wir jetzt das
ganze zum beispiel auf eine waschmittel
flasche draufsetzt und den verbrauch des
waschmittels mechanisch anders
zahnrädchen koppelt dann kann der
verbrauch über das handy getrackt werden
und könnte zum beispiel einstellen dass
das waschmittel neu bestellt wird bevor
es leer geht und nummer 3 drucken mit
bakterien wir bleiben beim 3d druck
gehen aber von kommunizierenden gegen
stedten hinzu lebenden organismen
schweizer forscher drucken mit lebender
tinte genannt flink functional living
thing was darin lebt sind bakterien die
bakterien nichts bakterien es gibt sehr
viele gute bakterien zum beispiel welche
die schädliche giftstoffe in rheine
zellulose umwandelt mit denen möchte man
jetzt zellulose hüllen für
organtransplantationen drucken oder
künstliche haut herstellen zu wissen
greepeace das rohr mit der barbie nummer
vier homosexualität entsteht im
mutterleib und zwar anscheinend bei
müttern die sehr viele söhne bekommen
sehr viele ältere brüder hat ist
häufiger schwul
diese beobachtung nennt man den vierten
albums order effekt nun hatte man
bislang noch keine biologische erklärung
dafür
kanadische forscher untersuchten das
blut von müttern die mit jungs schwanger
waren und sie fanden eine erhöhte
konzentration eines bestimmten
antikörpers für ein protein das nur bei
jungs oder männern gebildet wird die
theorie ist jetzt dass diese antikörper
konzentration im blut der mutter mit
jeder männlichen schwangerschaft steigt
diese antikörper könnten neuronal so
einfluss auf das gehirn des babys haben
dass die sexuelle orientierung dadurch
beeinflusst wird wohl gemerkt sind das
sehr neue ergebnisse basierend auf einer
eher klein studie daher sind diese
ergebnisse mit vorsicht zu genießen aber
interessant ist es allemal wunsch nummer
fünf betrunken sprechen wir besser
fremdsprachen das fanden holländische
forscher heraus und zwar sollte
niederländer
die niederländisch skills deutscher
muttersprachler bewerten und diejenigen
die vorher ein gläschen wein getrunken
hatten wurden besser bewertet als die
nüchternen solltet ihr euch also vor der
nächsten englisch klausur betrinken ich
bezweifle ist und die forscher auch da
in dem experiment nur sehr moderate
mengen an alkohol getestet wurden
außerdem auch nur die oralen sprach
skills wahrscheinlich hat das ganze nur
mit einem gewissen grad an enthemmung zu
tun bei größeren mengen an alkohol ist
mit einer verbesserung allerdings nicht
zu rechnen
oh là là alle paper über die ich heute
gesprochen habe sind natürlich unten
verlinkt fielen dann nochmal für euer
sehr positives feedback zu diesem
science news format ich werde euch jetzt
in zukunft regelmäßig auf dem laufenden
halten wir sehen uns nächste woche bis
dahin bleibt sicher